we live in an absolutely wild world but
one thing is for sure that people are
trusting the media less and less now
here's the latest example of why they're
losing trust we've got this report from
cbs news that claims the u.s economy has
been hit with increased gas prices
inflation and supply chain issues due to
the ukraine crisis now yes there is
inflation issues yes there's high gas
prices and there are supply chain
disruptions but the ukraine crisis
started like yesterday what are they
talking about this is classic
gaslighting it's simply taking problems
that have persisted for two years or
more and it's trying to use a brand new
current event to try to explain it away
this is classic political strategy is
use war use conflict to actually get
people to be okay with the problems in
their daily lives now let's take a look
at some of the underlying data here we
can see that gasoline prices have been
rising but they've been rising since the
beginning of 2020 since the beginning of
the pandemic that has nothing to do with
ukraine then if we continue we look at
this quote here what we have is the
chief economist from rsm saying as
costly as another european war would be
in human and economic terms its economic
burden in the united states would fall
hardest on the middle and working
classes that's true but what we have to
understand is that the burden is yet to
come it would happen in the future it's
not what has caused the things we've
already experienced if you understand
what's going on in russia with the oil
production then you're gonna start
paying attention what you understand is
that they produce about 10 of all oil
globally and if we sanction them if we
prevent them from exporting that oil yes
gasoline prices for americans will rise
there will be more and more issues but
that doesn't mean we get to use the
ukraine crisis as an explanation for the
bad undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policy and all of the issues around
inflation gasoline prices and supply
chain disruptions that have already been
going on for years if we now take a look
at the u.s inflation rate it's at seven
and a half percent in january of 2022
but go back it was over four percent in
april of last year did that have
anything to do with ukraine of course
not and so the media is gaslighting
americans the media is simply trying to
spin a narrative that is untrue if you
look at the data it is completely at
odds with what the media narrative is in
that cbs report now it would be
intellectually dishonest to say that the
ukraine crisis has had absolutely zero
impact on gasoline prices at all as you
can see here we were at about three
dollars and forty cents when the crisis
started today we're just about three
dollars and fifty cents but that is a
minuscule impact compared to what
they're trying to explain they are
trying to take the current conflict and
use it as an excuse for the problems
that we have as we head into midterm
elections expect more and more
gaslighting expect more and more stories
like this you as an individual you've
got to be able to look at what they're
saying and then go and check out the
data for yourself go to the primary
sources think for yourself do not allow
them to spin data and narrative to
explain away the problems we must hold
our politicians and our economic leaders
in check we must hold them accountable
and ultimately that's the responsibility
of every individual citizen hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time